You ready for me?
I’m Tim Feess
Victoria Tan
Sankalp Gosain
Leslie Chatelain
Mitch Adwon
Justin Cahill
Biniam Dawit
Demetrius Lewis
Megan Waters
Michael Chang
Matthew Douglas
Joey Cheek
Megan Leahy
Long Ellis
Lindsey Breuer
Mary Gamber
Caaminee Pandit
Hudson Andrews
Meliko Tawasa
Hi my name’s Carmen
Laura Martaindale
Oriana Poindexter
Dawn Zhao
Casey Boyles
Amanda Yamasaki
Madeleine Douglas
Jim Ressa
David Leyva
Ana Gonzalez
Rachel Sverdlove
Jacob Loewenstein
[overlapping names]
Hi, I’m Julia
I’m Jackie
Yasmin Belo-Osagie
[phone ringing]
Someone is calling me right now.
Is this on?
My favorite Princeton experience. That’s a really hard one.
It’s really hard to answer the question
of what’s my favorite experience.
My favorite Princeton moment was, winning the Ivy League
championships this year.
One of my favorite things at Princeton was the ‘Skate Nights.’
It was an event called Princeton Palooza where there was music,
and just like a lot of bands outside in the 1903 Courtyard. It
was Communiversity. It was a really wonderful day.
I guess my favorite Princeton experiences would be working with
Black Box Inc. and Hip Hop Art & Life.
Our favorite moment at Princeton… Was playing
on the squash team together.
Woo hoo! And house parties.
I would have to say, as bad as it sounds, my favorite experience
was writing my thesis.
My favorite Princeton moment was when I went to go turn in my
thesis. I was rushing from Firestone to 1879 and I ran into one
of my good friends giving a tour, and the entire tour cheered me
on as I made it the rest of the way to turn it in.
My favorite Princeton experience was freshman
seminar with Chris Eisgruber.
My favorite Princeton moment was meeting Sonya Sotomayor at the
Latinas at Princeton reception. It was a great experience and
she shared a lot of great Princeton memories.
My favorite Princeton moment was definitely getting the chance
to interview the Chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff.
When I was able to go abroad, for instance, to Beijing with
Princeton in Asia. And especially to Ghana with Engineers
Without Borders.
My favorite thing about Princeton was my opportunity to study
abroad in Cuba.
The best elements at Princeton: The faculty, the students, and
doing fun activities.
I think my favorite experience was like, getting to know all the
faculty in the Visual Arts program.
Last year, I had the honor of being the drum major of the
Princeton University band, so I got to lead the P-rade through
the Fitzrandolph gate leading the 25th reunion. And it was just
absolutely…just seeing all those orange and black jackets and
all those smiling faces and people who were so excited to see
us…absolutely was like, the best thing of my life and I can’t
wait to walk in the P-rade this year as a senior.
My favorite Princeton experience, definitely has to be every
year during reunions, the P-rade. Just seeing all the tradition,
all the orange, all the old alums, you know. Meeting alums that
are 100 years old and having them shake your hand, and just
having that experience together definitely gives you the sense
that Princeton is going to be part of your life forever.
Alright, but what are we going to say though?
I don’t know.
I am a chemistry major.
I’m a Woodrow Wilson School major.
Ecology and Evolutionary Biology
00:03:14.37,00:03:14.08
Politics
Operations Research and Financial Engineering
00:03:18.198,00:03:18.07
Italian
Economics
ORFE
00:03:20.18,00:03:20.07
Economics
Woodrow Wilson School
History
Classics
Religion
Sociology
Psychology
Politics
Political Psychology
Ecology and Evolutionary Biology
Art History major, but I did the Visual Arts track
History
Politics
Molecular Biology
Art & Archeology
Philosophy major
Economics
Politics
Woodrow Wilson School
History
German
English
Sociology
Molecular Biology
Computer Science
Chemisty major
Politics
History
Operations Research and Financial Engineering
Psychology
Chemistry
Woodrow Wilson School
English
Classics
Woodrow Wilson School
Civil Engineer
Economics
Psych and a Spanish certificate
English and certificates in African American Studies and the
program in Teacher Preparation
Art & Archeology
Sociology
East Asian Studies
Computer Science B.S.E.
The Econ Department
English
Woody Woo
Politics
Woody Woo major
ORFE
ECON
Math
Molecular Biology
Economics
Woodrow Wilson School
Politics
History of Science
Civil Engineer
History major
Certificate in Material Science
Electrical Engineer
Certificate in Material Science and Engineering
Theater certificate
Ohh, so nervous!
I guess what helped me get through Princeton was probably a lot
of support from my friends and family.
The people who helped me get through Princeton are my closest
friends: People I eat with, people I study with, people I party
with. It really is an incredible group of intellectuals and good
people.
All my good friends and roommates
My family and my friends here at Princeton
My roommates have been extraordinary. I was very lucky to be
placed with three amazing girls in my freshman quad and I’m
still living with them as a senior. And we’re all different
races and its been a real lesson in how to interact across
racial boundaries.
My parents, and my sister
My roommates, and my parents and my brother
My parents definitely. Um, God….don’t think I would’ve made it
through.
My thesis advisor, my live advisor. I could not have done it
without him.
The Varsity Women’s Ice Hockey team and all my teammates and
coaches
Definitely the teammates on the Crew team and the other
Chemistry majors were a huge help.
Shirley Tilghman, she was an inspiration. And has taught me to
try and become as professional and inspirational as she is.
Definitely having a very very kind thesis advisor
I think, all my class experiences
The great professors at Princeton helped me to succeed, and I
hope that I’ll go on in the future and be an academic like them.
I think, my friends here helped me get through the Princeton
experience…as well as Frist, especially when it’s open 24 hours
which it should be all the time.
Frist Campus Center as an entity. It’s a good place to meet all
your friends.
What got me through Princeton? Uh, gallons of coffee
Definitely the 24 hour access to 185 the art building for the
Lewis Center
I think there is a lot of solidarity among students at
Princeton.
I guess my friends really got me through Princeton. Wouldn’t
have made it without ‘em.
My friends
My family and friends
Uh, friends
My friends pretty much got me by.
All of my friends
My friends
I couldn’t have done it without the friends that I made here.
I’m so grateful that I met them and I’m going to be friends with
them forever.
[music]
Four years are actually a really short time. Coming in as a
Freshman, I thought four years would be an eternity, but they’re
not.
Do anything and everything you want to and don’t hold back.
Remember that four years just goes by so quickly, so enjoy every
moment, every day, even the hard days. It’s worth it. It’s such
a great place to be. We’re so blessed.
Today, you leave this privileged place as the beneficiaries of a
world class education.
One that I hope has prepared you well for whatever comes next,
including the unexpected.
So as you walk, skip, or run through the Fitzrandolph gates
today as educated citizens of this and many other nations, I
hope you will carry forward the spirit of Princeton and all it
has sought to teach you. Aim high and be bold!
[music]
It’s sad, it’s so sad.
But we know we’ll be friends past this so it’s ok.
[music]
Getting some good hard work, getting work done, and doing it for
Princeton.